Evet arkadaşlar hepinize Merhaba bugün
bir yolculuğa çıkacağız
başlangıçtan bugüne doğru geleceğiz
Yolculuk esnasında neler yaşanmış
olamadıysanız aslında şu
ilanı büyük patlama zannettiğimiz
gibi bizim bildiğimiz anlamda bir şey
olmaması gerekiyor bundan 13,8 milyar
yıl öncesine her bakarsınız
O günden sonra ne oldu İlk Yıldızlar ilk
galaksiler basit Honda canlılar belki
evrenörü tarafından vardır ama
muhtemelen sizin gibi sürekli sınav
sorusu
çözer ve daha karmaşık canlılar zeka
ekonomi verdiler
beni yaşam öyküsü bu
ve bizimle Bir yıldızımız Var Bir
Galaksi içerisindeyiz bu galakside başka
bir kümenin
Güneş adını öğrenmişiz
aşırı ısıtılmış Kral basitçe
ve bizden
[Müzik]
Yani ışık olsanız
ki olamazsınız Muhtemelen fotoğrafta
dünyayı gören dediğimiz hemen şöyle
yakınlaştıralım
orada bir yerde o şükürler olsun o kadar
güneşe yakın
değil ölçek olarak doğrunun 13.000
kilometre çapında bir gezegenimiz
şimdi
ölçeği
büyütmeden önce Eğer Her sabah doğan
güneşe uygun gözlem araçları ile
baksaydınız böyle bir şey görürdünüz
dikkat ederseniz
altın parçalarına benzeyen şeyler var
Her biri Türkiye'den daha büyük
boyutlara sahip ve canlı olarak
izleseydiniz böyle bir şey görüyoruz
yüzeyin altında ısınan gaz yüzeye doğru
çektikçe soğuyup tekrar Hüseyin'in
altına doğru hareket ediyor
[Müzik]
Bize yıldızımız biraz Öte
ancak bize yeteneği Yıldız güçlü bir
yıldız isimli onun içerisindeki kırmızı
hücreli yıldız var dropsima
Yaklaşık 4
uzak
Lara hemen aktarıyorum şu imalatında
anlaşıldığı gibi bir zaman diyebilirim
bir mesafeyi belirtiyor Işığın bir yılda
aldığı yol yaklaşık 9,5 milyon kilo
4 ışık yılı Yaklaşık 40 milyon eurovisi
bundan 10.000 yıl sonra biz EYT
Burası ise daha yeni
olacak ve galaksimiz birbirinden bir
Galaksi ile birisiyiz dedeler misiniz
Biz hiçbir şekilde zannediyorduk yemek
yediğimiz tabakları düşünün iki tane
yeteneğinizde bahçe koyarsanız bir
Galaksi çiçekler de dersiniz yandan bak
kenarlarına doğru disk uzanır ancak biz
fark ettik ki aslında Galaksi bizim
kenarları da biraz
ve biz orada gördüğünüz Güneş sembolünün
olduğu yerde İsrail misiniz Ben 26.000
şifremizi merkezinden
peki
Biz Eğer
biliyorsunuz tüm sahte bir günde
özellikle astrolojinin beslendiği şey
sabitlemektir aslında Bugün konuşmamız
felsefelerinin sabit olmadığını da
Göstereceğim biraz yani sağmayı
öğrenelim doğası daha kötü bir şey
Herkes için fotoğraf
şimdi burada bir video var ve bu videoyu
hızlandırılmış şekilde size Önümüzdeki 5
milyon yılda 2 milyon galaksinin
yıldızın nasıl hareket ettiğ
ini dikkat ederseniz yıldızların
şekilleri değişiyor
burçlar da takım yıldızları olduğuna
göre Dede gelecek kısmet ediyorum
burçların şekli de verilmiş
yani bugünün Terazi burcunda olanlar
neden terazi vermiş terazi'ye benzediği
için yıldızları içinde teraziye
yarım sefer tasarıma
burcun ne sefer kası
Sana yolculuk görevlileri yani
evladım ki sabit iş şey diyor buna şuan
sorunun orada sabit olduğumuzu
düşünebilirsiniz
ve sabit değil atomlarınız bile Şu an
bir
titrelik
ve şimdi bir video ile gelen sizin
vermesine gideceğiz bu çok taze bir
video daha saatlerce açıklanan bir keşif
galaksinin merkezindeki Süper deliklerde
değil fotoğrafını
şöyle bir video Hatta ışığı kapatırsak
daha muhteşem bir görüntü elde
edebiliriz sevgili eşim
bunun içerisinden geçir galaksisinin
merkezindeki süper ve Karadeniz 4 milyon
Güneş ülkesinde
ve oda yapımının çapı birkaç 10 milyon
ışık yılı dikkate göndermekte galiba ve
baktığınızda böyle bir şey
işte bu
görüntüsünü elde ettiği yersiniz Size en
yakın
Dertlerimiz sıkıntılarımız
ı sevmediğiniz insanları
atabileceğiniz yer
Muhtemelen eylemimizde kaynağımızda
boyatmak isteyeceksiniz tamam mı yan
kaydı
bu 26 gün ışık yılı uzaklıklarında bize
daha yakın karakteri lider var Ancak
görsünler dediğiniz Karadeniz
bu 26 bin kişilik yılı uzakta Şimdi
galaksimizde
dışarıya çıktığımızda bakıyoruz acaba
Başka gelen kişiler var mı Evet var
antropi de galaksisini görüyorsunuz Bize
en yakın
sarmal galaksisi bizden Biraz daha büyük
ve Yaklaşık 4 milyar yıl içerisinde bu
dominasyonunu görüyorsunuz bizim
galaksimizi görüyorsunuz sonra durumu
olarak yapacağız ve gruptaki diğer bir
felaksama kan grubuyla
Bryan grubunun isimli bir Galaksi var
biraz daha küçük sorun yaratılacağımızı
ancak
yaklaşık
4000 andrometresini belası bize çarpacak
şimdi elektrik arıza toplama ekran
koymayın daha 4'lü yani
sorun değil ve çarpıştığında bir
değişiklik Galaksi halinde olacak
burada baktığımız ölçekler artık
milyonlarca ışık yılı çarpı bir ölçüye
bakıyoruz ardından denizler iki buçuk
milyon ışık yılı uzaklıkta bekliyorum
Çıplak gözle görebileceğiniz en uzaktan
ve bunu da büyüttüğünüzde
Burada da aslında ışığı kapatabiliriz
sevgili
Okey hiçbir şey Fark etmedi Teşekkürler
Bu
bir dost Sky şimdi bakın küçük
ölçeklerden büyük ölçeklere doğru
gidiyorum yani genel durumumuz var
yanımızda değil ilko kümesi var değil ya
bunların hepsinin
daha bir süper
yani orada gördüğünüz o nokta var
aslında birer galaksi grub gösteriyor
nokta toplulukları birer enerji
çapındaki bir yere bakıyoruz şu an
ve büyük bir yüzde bunu layerde
bir süper ülkeye ulaşıyoruz bu süper
orada gördüğünüz o bölgenin çapı
yaklaşık olarak 500 milyon
çıkıp geçerse çevresinde Başka sefer
Lanetli halay dilinde mutsuz bucaksız
cennet demek
gök cisimleri Biz tarihli isimlerdir
yani gezegen her galakssız her Galaksi
kelimeler
dünyayı demişiz Toprak
ve evrenin tomografisini çekersek eğer 5
milyarlık şirk gibi öteye bakarsak
orada yanıt veren her şey bir galaksi
İşte o galaksilerden biri ise gözlerini
bilir herhalde 2 trilyonun başka bir
Galaksi olabilir
burada baktığımız ölçek Yaklaşık 5
milyar Işık
Peki biz daha uzaklara görebiliyormuş
Evet bu da son zamanlarda dönüyoruz
sorumludur evrak olarak Yıldız
sabahleyin zamanla ilgili güzel resimler
şu an baktığınız o küçük kırmızı nokta
gösteren
12,9 milyar yıl öncesine ait bir ışık
Ancak o onun 12,9 milyar Işıklı
uzaklıkta olduğunu gösterdi aksine şu an
elimizde alsak yeter videomuzu beğeni
değiştirmesine zor olursa bizden
uzaklığı 28 milyar aşı
veren çünkü onun ışığı yolculuğa
başladığında helaliyetinde duramıyoruz
sürekli
ve daha da uzakları görebiliyor muyuz
Evet bu da Yeni keşif birkaç hafta önce
fotoğrafını görüyorsunuz Şu an şu an
farklı kırmızı nokta görüntülerindeki
dile getirip içsel gelmiş
[Müzik]
13,5 milyar yıl öncesine ait galaksinin
görüntüsü bizden şu an özellikle
yaklaşın 34.000 gibi yani işte
ve Peki bizim görebileceğimiz ve bizzat
fiziksel olarak gidebileceğimiz bir
sınır var mı Evet
şu an Bulunduğumuz noktadan
13-14 milyar ışık yılı Küresi ile veya
bir küreye ulaşırsınız ve oranın
özelliği şudur
Oradaki her şey sizden Işık hızı
olacaktır
yani O gördüğünüz daire içerisindeki her
şeyin ışığı Bugün yola çıksa şu an nasıl
konuşurken size öyle de sonunda ulaşır
Eğer bir yerlerde
Ancak o çizginin ötesinde başka bir
bölge var Evren genişlerken fabl püresi
de değişiyorlar yani belli bir mesafe 16
milyarışık yıla gittiğinizde de bu
geçerli Orada bizim kozmik olayı konusu
var Aynen yakaladığımız bir olayı böyle
bildiğin son geldi
ne zaman dolayı şu an gerçekleşen bir
olayın yani 16 milyar ışık yılı
gittiğiniz daha bu süresini biraz daha
taşındı ise Orada herhangi bir Galaksi
uzaya geldiği Işık size bugün Ancak
bugün yola çıkışı Siz az kalmıştı
[Müzik]
ve ışığı sana ulaşmak için niyetlerin
cezalara vardı
yani ne kadar uzağa bakarsanız
görebileceğiniz şu an gerçekleşen bir
olayı acaba gelecekteki görebilecek
miyim sorusunun yanında 16 milyar
şekilde içerisinde evet ancak 16 milyar
Işık yılıdan daha önce gittiğimiz zaman
ki görselleri 33 milyar çekiyordur yani
gördüğünüz görselde ben güneş sistemi
var
ondan göze bir evrenin sınırına doğru
gittiğimize yaklaşık 43
parmak 46 buçuk milyar ışık yılı bir
mesafeden bahsediyoruz ve biz konuşurken
büyümeye
Demek ki bizim bizzat gidebileceğimiz
ışık hızından ışık hızına giden
gittiğimi yaptırması hayaletin hiçbir
zaman isim O işte adokrasiler biraz daha
belli olmaz
o kozmik olayını kullanabilmesi için
aslında geçemezsiniz Çünkü siz bir adım
at
arak parasıdır
Ancak bu güneş sistemi gösterebilir ev
reni kendi gözlenebilir evrenin
merkezindeyim sizi de öylesiniz
oturduğunuz sandalye
evrenin kendisini gözlenebilir evrenden
birkaç yüz kat daha büyük olduğunu
düşünüyoruz Yani biraz daha sağa kaçsam
başka bir gözlemeviyle evlenir misin
[Müzik]
Herkesi kendi gözlenebilir evrenin
merkezinde
dikkat ederseniz hiçbir şeyin olmadığı
bir slaytla başladım Çünkü büyük
baklavadan önce ne oldu
diyoruz Hatta tam o t-0
olarak da
öyle görünüyor diye evlenelim ölüm
senaryolarından artık de ister
sonunda
yıldızları Hepsi sönecek bu zaten
görüyorsunuz Yaşamın kendisine ilk doğan
her şeyi istiyor sonra
bu evin kendisi için de geçerli
Yıldızlar sürecek galaksiler sürecekse
tekrar
kontrolün Doyum var işleri bir yer
haline gelecek
Ancak o hamile O durumda değil herhangi
başka bir şey bulup yeni bir Evren Tabii
ki Doğa bir
yani size şu ana kadar anlattığım şey
birincisi evlenemeyiz sabit olmadığı
ve ikincisi evrende gidebileceğiniz
görebileceğiniz yani Her gördüğünüz yere
şu an kalkıp gidemeyeceğiniz anda
var Ancak
o sınırın Orada olması ondan ötesinde
bir şey olmadığı anlamına gelen
bizzat sanırım orada olması O sizin
arkasında bir şey oldun diye yani Kanıt
akarsa
Peki Tüm bu teknolojik gelişmişliğe
rağmen Tüm bu ilerleme geri rahatına
hepimiz aydınlatır mı insan mı denir
burada evet
insanlar Çünkü iki tane nöron
harcamayacağınız harcamanız gerek
olmayacak şeyleri dedim beyin
enerjisisini harcamak kalmış
size bak bile bak biliyim demek gibi his
yükleyerek beni iddia ederler var
evrene enerji gönderip bunu nakite
çevirebilenler var
işte hiç anlamını bilmediği halde orayı
burayı puan almak kelimesinin
sertleştiler var
Ben onları oksijen israf ediyorum
randevu almak istiyorum
yani
Biz aydınlanıyoruz
gökyüzünden ilham aldık insanın tarihine
bakarsanız birçok yıkamalık günümüze
bakarken de bunu
birkaç milimetre çapındaki şu göz
merceği ile yaptık aslında
ilham alarak buralara geldik yani bu
konuşmadan sonra
gökyüzüne bakarken
gökyüzüne Sadece su içerken farklı
geçmişinizin orada olduğunu
geleceğimizin orada olduğunu
[Müzik]
unut ve evrende sabit hiçbir şeyin
olmadığı yönü
eğlenin sürekli değiştiğini geliştiğini
aklınızda tutun yerinizde saymayın
sürekli ilerleyin
Evet hepinize teşekkür ediyorum
Dilediğiniz için